You've hit your alarm and clocked in.
But are you really ready for the workday?
If you think you'll be better prepared for that meeting later in the day,...
...think again.
It turns out there is a best time of day to do everything at work,...
...according to science.
Take it from experts Business Insider, The Huffington Post,...
...and The Washington Post spoke with.
Despite the initial grogginess, we get happier and enjoy work more in the mornings,...
...according to a study published in the British Journal of Psychology.
But the party stops around noon,...
...so schedule meetings and calls during happier morning hours.
You're also less distracted in the morning...
...and quicker and more accurate when completing tasks,...
...says author Daniel Pink in his bestselling book about timing.
Since you're already alert and energy levels are up,...
...experts say you should leave simple tasks like checking email for later,...
...and tackle the hard stuff as soon as possible...
...since alertness plummets during the afternoon.
Taking a lunch break is important for people with a lot on their plate...
...so fill it with some food instead.
Your brain tends to crash around 2:00 or 3:00,...
...so experts suggest grabbing some coffee and even a 20-minute power nap.